HOW'S it going, bros? :3
Like Pewdiepie wasn't loud enough already... (no seriously)
How's it going, bros? My name is PewDiePie (we know...)
Today, we're gonna play some of the most quality,
finest,
*pedophile voice* video games...(because I don't do that EVERY day anyway...)
*Poods smokes bad edited vape juice (VAPE INTENSIFIES)
This game is about the afterlife. (Oooohhh I wanna see)
Don't be afraid, hold my hand! *grabs your face*
We're doing this together... (so we are gonna die together? Dying with Pewds...hmm, I'd rather Mark...)
After life.... THE GAME (and finally the game is introduced. Quality shit, Pewds.)
It's gonna be okay .... (PROTECT ME PEWDS)
WHEEEEEEEW FLYYYY
Oh okay, we start off as a ghost
Oh, it's Flappy bird (Pewds nightmare basically. So much rage...)
Got it, gotttt it. It's flappy ghost
Niiicee (2sp00ky4me
)
Don't hit anything ( omg dont you DARE)
*zooms in on PewDieGhost's blank eyes.*
Gonna make it to hell,,, just chill with satan. (you dont chill with satan, satan chill with you)
And hitler... (sounds like a party to me)
*OMG NICE FACE PEWDS*  And Jacksepticeye (#obsessedwithdaddyjack)
*Silence Intensifies*
CLEAN YO COMPUTER PEWDS
*Pewds realizes that porn in on his computer and his 12 year old dreams come true*
*Pewds thinks to himself: Damn she thicc
Oh we gotta clean our computer OH MY GOD WE GOTTA CLEAN
no one can find our weird porn (Remember when you revealed your porn history in the Walking Dead? )
Oh god we have special porn? Aghhh no Not da special porn.... (WTFPEWDS)
Okay Let's just get rid of the My little Pony... (I mean the my little pony stuff wasnt that good anyways)
Let's delete the porn ( This is torture for Pewds By the way)
No! Not the special porn
*Sad dramatic music* I cant look! (We all feel for you)
*More sad dramatic music* (and a clip from I Am Legend)
Okay now let's delete our history ( Hey, 'Interracial man contemplates a banana'...Mark gtfo. )
Interracial man, Proper way to open a coconut BESSIE THE BEAST, hagay??, Pewdieplier, oh god we ca... mart
Oh that's funny , a bunch of references
What do I need to do? AH dont ??? me bruh
*Pewds is concentrated mode* Ahh wut da fuck!
You failed to protect your wife from danger
This is our wife? ( Pewds is married to Marzia confirmed. Let the fanfictions begin. )
Aight, Alright lady
uhhh Bam!
Be gone poop!
Why is there poop? That's right mah lady I willl protect you fro-
all the spikey
SANIK F**K OFF
DYAH!
OH! F*ck YEAH
REVENGE! ahh okay ummm Alan, What did Alan do?
*Zoom in on Alan's blank face*That's right Alan I will F*ck your sh*t  up
YEAH THAT'S RIGHT ALAN I BET YOU SCARED
YOU SON OF A B*TCH
Ya fucking Pu*sy
What is this?! Is that Jack? XD That's jack XD
*PEWDIE SCREECH* TOP OF THE MORNING TO YA LADDIES
*the face Pewds makes when he really needs to take a Sh*t
TOP OF THE MO!!!
AAAAAHHH
XD What da F*ckk is this?!
Ahhh So I'm spooking people's videos games?
THAT'S RIGHT JACK YOU SCARED B*TCH
PARTY TIEM
UH UH UH
i'M SH... WHAT THE F-
OH I just gotta click
*Pewds turns Super saiyan*
*Beat Intensifies*
*Orgasm?*
THis is really hard ( thats what she said huehuehue )
I'm almost as good as in real life (yeah right)
DUNK IT! (Get dunked on)
Waddup Edgar
Yehhh that's right
ahh shit
OHHH MISSED ME BITCH
OHHHYOUGOTTADRINKBITCH (SATAN GOT DUNKED ON)
Oh we gotta dress up
I'll be deadpool (D31DP009 got that swag)
Oh for haloween
Should I be a human?
Says his name
Choose! I dont know Stairway to heaven I guess? (They are both good songs Pewds)
*multiple 'WHOO's*
(Pewds releasing his inner dog)
Yeahhhhh, Welcome to heaven
Alrightt
Tilen Poca- I'm not going to try to pronunce that ( you uncultured turd. Check your privilege, Pewds )
Tilan Maya?
Great job on the game
That was really fun, really cool, really creative, very nice VERY MUCH I LIKE IT
NEXT GAME
*whispers creepily* "dont spill your coffee*
*determined voice* Look at that guy, that guy is ready not to spill his coffee
oh my god! WHAT THE HELL
am i do- ahhhh
My life is horrible AHH My FACCE, MY FAAACE
No wonder im bald
Aight here we go heyy how's it going everyon
santa claus here
huehue
bababda bababadi  (pewds lost it) XD
Oh god that's my face right
lets uh, lets uhhh ahh F*ck my life
jesus christ
This is ridiculous
Do I gotta click that button? (YES) It looks like it
now how does one click a button (you click it -.-)
with mah butt? (Pewds derp voice activated)
OH MY f*CKING GOD
That is the dumbest and best thing I've ever Heard. *Seen
(Pewds gets stuck) no No NO
you can do it, you can do it get up get up
come on buddy come on buddy dont give up
*pewds starts singing...* oh no... DONT STOP NOW NEVER GIVE UP HOLD YOUR HEAD HIGH
AND REACH THE TOP LET THE WORLD SEE WHAT YOU YOU ARE A DOLPHIN! THAT'S IT YOU ARE A DOLPGIN YOU DID IT
YEHHAEEEH Is that how a dolphin sounds yeghghtt
Oh my god! it works oh okay alright jesus christ
How's it going everyon- WOOOOOH I did it!
I did it! Level2 there's more levels? goddamnit
touch it with mah ass, touch it with mah ass touch it with mah ass
my nipples have burn- have melted I cant feel them
There we go there it is
AGAIN OMG PEWDS!  NAILED IT aww nice
squat time xD I dont even know how to squat in real life
how am i su- OH SH- aww
alright move your butt
ahh nice oh we can squat alright lets squat
Are you F*cking kidding me right now, dude I squatted
What else do you want from me?
*spills coffee* NOPE *bends back* XD
come on squat....
F*ck...
YEAH!!!
Everyon- *BREAKDANCES*  yeahhhhhh
everyone is wondering why I am late for the meeting
sickest breakdance ever that's why (thug life pewds)
How do I get my ass up in the air you know what I mean? (No i dont pewds XD)
like I just dont care
OKay now we're gonn- we're gonn- oh my god
*chokes*
uh ohhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh
WHAT THE F*CKKKK  THAT WAS SO CLOSE
COME ON COME ON GET OUT OF THERE
*Parrot noises* When I'm walking the wall? XD
You gotta bend up then go right back down
Bend that a*s up *falls* F*ck
*sexy silence*
OHHH that is some sexy Sh*t
Right fu*king there!
That was a really cool game check it out , link in the description
Next game Mr. MAtthew!
for the last game we're gonna play a game that didn't pay me for this (oh....)
I wouldnt pay anyone for this
BUT! in this game called Thumbdrift we got the  Nizawn
*INTENSE SWAG*
I didn't expect, this I think that's awesome
It says BRO-FIST, on the front
Here we go alright this is the training map
This Nishawn goes real f*ckin fast mahn
look att this sh*t
It's got a B4 engine
With extra Cluchius
Oh god so this game is actually really difficult XD
I'm very bad at it
Come on baby
WOOOH Give me that coin!
Oh man this Nishawn baby baby
AHHHS*HT
PEWDIEPIEE
How Do  I drive the car? I dont know (Pewds it's your car)
All I know is drift, and drift hard (Damn right daddy)
Edgar is driving the car, all I am doing is sitting at the front, that's it
This music makes me wanna sniff cocaine and party all night, I really like it (Ill join you on that)
Come on! I need more coins! (HE IS ONLY IN IT FOR THE MONEY, MONEY MONEY MONEY!)
I need to get better at this
PEEEDEPIE (i tried my best)
OKay f*ck it you get the point
That was three free games with pewds
Thank you matthew as always
uhhh check out these free games (I wont )
It's uh That's the point of the show
BUT ALSO! dont forget to leave a like I really appreciate it
Thanks for watching I hope you enjoyed and as always I'll see you tomorrow in the next video... Stay awesome bros *BROFIST*
Did I just do my outro in the wrong camera? That is f*cking emberassing xD
Oh my god, okay *kisses fist* *Brofist*
(~˘▾˘)~
~(˘▾˘~)
(ʘ‿ʘ) BYE